let's understand rational numbers and
irrational numbers a bit more writing
rational numbers in the decimal format
gives us a better understanding for
example 1.5 is already in its decimal
form
this is a terminating decimal this means
that after the decimal point the number
terminates
if we try writing 5 over 6 in the
decimal format we get this
if we see that it is not terminating
that means it is non-terminating and
recurring
this means the number repeats after the
decimal point if we solve for negative 7
over 12 we see that this is also
non-terminating recurring but if we take
irrational numbers which cannot be
written in the p over q form like root 2
or root 3 and try writing them in the
decimal format we see that they are
non-terminating which means they don't
end
and are also non-recurring which means
there is no particular pattern here
rational numbers can either be
dominating or non-terminating recurring
irrational numbers are always
non-terminating and non-recurring